[Music]
what about art now can you think of
things that do still succeed in you know
rising above this suffocation you know
examples perhaps you can all draw from
your own experiences of of sublime in
stuff that's being made and generated
and put out there not necessarily in
particular physics but in the world
day-to-day
i mean
is it invisible is it non-existent i
thought it was interesting in in the
introduction you mentioned um the whap
video and um
some i don't know if you know for people
who are not familiar with it it's um
nicki minaj and megan lee stallion have
a video which is incredibly raunchy
and
you know we see that i guess more as
trashy than transcendent
and personally i kind of agree not that
it's trashy but i don't find it
empowering from a feminist perspective i
think it's you know it's it's it's uh
catering very much to the male gaze even
though it's also subverting it somehow
um but i do think that it's really
important to to say that
um i guess for younger generations my
sense is that what older generations and
like our ancestors thought of as the
sublime today for young people is uh
maybe
characterized more by things that are
magical or
epic or sensational um and there's
something about that video for instance
that gets people talking and it's
there's something to analyze in it
there's also this
kind of resistance to the sublime which
has always been you know very classed as
i said um it's very like the sublime is
a space which has uh really constricted
people's behavior um and and been very
normative and said you know this is how
your
you're a lady or whatever and there's
something in this in this video that's
saying that no we don't want to be
socially acceptable you know this is
something different um and it's also
kind of
uh it's it's blurring the lines between
pornography
i guess and art
which the kind of old
old-fashioned school would say oh no you
can't do that but i i just think that
people who are into that
kind of art form that art expression are
also seeking something sublime i can't
help but see a similarity there to
to to gospel music in the 18th 19th
century as a as a way of something very
powerful and transcendent tied to
christianity and latterly after that
jazz i mean you know
these things really it seems to me have
broken these levels but you know i just
wanted to have some some more examples
of perhaps guide the way we can get back
to it that are happening in our
contemporary culture
oh that's true beyond the wetlands i
think it's uh hopeless i'm afraid i
think the sublime is completely dead
there's there's a couple of amazing um
composers max richter if anyone's heard
of him
wonderful composers that take you there
but i have to say um you know we we were
all asked actually to watch um
the whap video and we were asked also uh
to look at this art by a japanese artist
by um murakami and i don't know if any
of you have seen this whack video
but um
actually i watched it i mean was very
interesting i was thanking whoever
decided we should watch it because this
is my first introduction to modern uh
culture
and
and actually i found myself singing sort
of a long
uh there are halls in the house and the
doors and the house
um it was it was it was a good song
and and actually it's um i think if art
is an expression of a culture it
absolutely in fact both of them
absolutely express our own culture i
mean you know what are our obsessions
sex and shopping murakami looked like it
and designed a shower curtain for kids
for tesco you know this is what we do
in fact as for the sort of um in a
minute of the feminist angle i thought
that was astonishing though my mother
used to say to me um
women will always be more powerful men
than men because we have what men want
our bodies and i think that is the sort
of message of this
sort of reclaiming our sexuality um
video but i have to say the language was
um really shocking to me
you know i want to gag
i want to feel pain
you know you know did all these things
to me please and it was like what is
that about and the trouble is it might
be totally totally clever but the people
who are watching it and getting aroused
and by it aren't they might not be super
clever
and you know and and women on the whole
aren't super beautiful like look i hope
all of you are going to be watching it
when you go home tonight it's really
sexy it works
um
but as for sublime uh i fear i fear it
is really really uh gone dead and gone
well
well i hear quite a lot of sublime
applause or laughter or whatever i hear
i hear people alive in this tent and if
if the sublime is part of being alive
how do you fit do we rupert minnow
perhaps you could square the idea that
it's dead i mean are we not going a bit
too far if we say that the sublime is
dead in the modern world are we really
that stuffed
well i'm afraid i didn't do my homework
and
you got a different kind of [ __ ] and
yes i'm afraid i haven't actually seen
the whop video yet
obviously i have to watch it when i get
home but
so i don't have an opinion about it
but i would say that in
we live in a very secularized culture
and anything to do with god or religion
is usually filtered out of public life
it's simply you can't you know no one
ever goes to church or sings hymns or
praise on television or anything it it's
been privatized everything to do with
religions being privatized
and when they were doing the downton
abbey series somebody asked why didn't
they ever show them saying grace before
meals because at that time they would
have said grace before meals
the answer is because it might have
offended atheists
to have grace on television
so we we live in a culture where
secularism isn't just um seen as a way
of
not
um favoring one religion over another
but the default position is
non-religious or even anti-religious
so i think there's something about
modern culture which is actually
amputating
the the transcendent and the sublime but
it can't be amputated from human nature
which is why
it keeps coming up again in all these
different forms and i think in the
modern world the main way in which
people experience it a lot of young
people experience it is through a kind
of psychedelic rite of passage which i
think for many people is an opening to
this realm that our education and our
culture tends to suppress
so i think that's one way i think there
are also various arts i mean i know this
is a terribly niche minority
interest coral even song in cathedrals
um but there are composers still writing
exquisitely beautiful music sir john
taverner for example um so it which is
performed in cory it's not just 16th
century polyphonic music
there's modern composers writing music
which is designed to be elevating and
and and inspiring and actually is in
many cases
so it's not as if it's gone away it's
just that it's been marginalized and or
all sort of put beneath the the radar
even though cathedrals are pretty large
hard to miss um lots of people have
never been into them because it's simply
not part of secular culture or education
to think about these things so i think
we have had a kind of general
suppression of the sublime in the name
of so-called science and reason
oh gosh do you mind if i say something
please do no no no but you remind me
that story of the cathedral you remind
me of that because about 15 years ago
i was on a train with a young lad of 20
and i saw he was reading a philosophy
book and anybody who reads a philosophy
book i love them of course i do and of
course i had to talk to him what was he
reading what was he doing etc
this this boy this young man
was a decorator he had left school at 16
because because school was completely
boring and he was going to see
sainz
salisbury cathedral because it was the
most beautiful
building in the world the most sublime
building in the world and he was going
to listen to even song
so there he was he was going to look at
this building he was he was going to to
listen to this music and he was reading
a book on philosophy but
he left school at 16 because our
education is so
boring
um what was he doing he should have been
at university he should have been you
know thinking being but he was there on
a train what was he doing
and that's i think it shows you know the
sublime is dead
if he has to do that
but i just
very quickly um you know we're at an
ideas and arts festival and
obviously people here are interested in
philosophy and these big big ideas but
also i've been you know catching lots of
very young artists who are performing
amazing music like there's lots of jazz
there's bulgarian indigenous music so i
think we also need to just insert that
the sublime is perhaps not entirely
and i gone
i mean hasn't hasn't every culture has
always sort of protested its own demise
it's almost again it's like you know
every culture announces its own
senescence as well so you know like the
sort of commode argument sense of an
ending and i agree with miller there's
fantastic work going on there's you know
arthur jeffers exhibition was great all
sort of found objects and creating kind
of beautiful art from sort of the
randomness of life or dorothy cross she
makes you know bathtubs you know she
puts instead of the scum line she puts
kind of you know gold leaf into it so
you sort of transmute mortality into oh
then there's great work going on i could
carry on and but um mark asked me to
talk about uh civilizational damage and
darkness too
one of the dark forces at work here that
makes such intelligent people seem so
gloomy about well i think okay there's
one
just to really yeah
so the one thing that can because i
think i was reading i was interested in
sublime as the unfathomable the
incomplete
and
and i think there is a sort of
civilizational damage that is going on
so lots of the art i know about i find
out from the internet so it's wonderful
in many ways but there's also this sort
of binary culture that's going on which
is the culture of the sort of bit you
know this sort of basic
you know kind of binary digit the most
basic unit of computing and
bear with me but this is either zero or
one everything is one thing or the other
and it means that when you go in these
kind of decision tree worlds you have
these formulated choices for you this or
that and it completes everything for you
and i think this entire culture friend
unfriend like dislike
everything is sort of decided for you
can only have one or the other and maybe
if we're going to reclaim the sublime
it's going to exist in the sort of again
going beyond all of that this sort of
civilizational damage i think that's
coming through as part of our own
culture maybe your you know your man on
the train is absolutely right to kind of
go off to salisbury cathedral instead
you know switch off his phone or
whatever it is but what i'd love to say
to minna
just about jazz because i've been
noticing this
that i listened to music with different
parts of my body
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas